[Music]
selena gomez is
flexing her britney fandom oh my
goodness
on tuesday the pop star shared this
throwback video to her instagram
featuring a pre-famed selena singing
along to the britney spears song
don't go knocking on my door selena
captioned the video
the hustle was real
[Music]
and down in the comments amy schumer
wrote stop it the britney track was
released in 2000
and was featured on her iconic album
oops i did it again
and lucky selena the admiration is
mutual
in 2018 britney shared this video of her
working out to selena's song
bad liar
britney captioned the post long workout
today selena gomez definitely helped me
get through it
um there's a king-size space bigger than
it used to be
if you want
[Music]
in 2016 britney and selena participated
in a benefit single alongside other
artists
but they've yet to join forces in the
recording studio one on one
and that same year spears responded to a
fan question about a potential collab
tweeting but when are we working on our
actual duet selena gomez
[Music]